A time-honored method of settling disputes,
trial by combat became an institution in Europe
during the Middle Ages.
Although it fell out of fashion for many,
beginning with the Enlightenment, it remained
a popular means for European nobility to settle
matters of honor well into the 19th century.
While most duels were fought by men, occasionally
a ladies’ disagreement would get out-of-hand,
and the resulting “petticoat duel” would
commence.
One of the earliest of these recorded was
between Diambra de Pettinella and Isabella
de Carazzi in Naples in 1552, when the two
couldn’t agree on which of them should win
the heart of Fabio de Zeresola.
While the outcome remains unknown, the battle
between them was memorialized in the painting
of Jose de Ribera, Duela de Mujeres (1636).
Over the years, lady duels were fought between
actresses challenging each other’s craft,
society mavens over who should take precedence
at an event, and two ladies, Madame Astie
de Valsayre and “Miss Shelby”, even clashed
over whether American or French doctors were
superior.
As noted in an article published in Le Petit
Parisien on March 17, 1886,
Mme Astié de Valsayre, known for having published
several books, has just been to Waterloo for
a fencing duel with an American, Miss Shelby.
During a debate on the superiority of French
female doctors over American female doctors
she had thrown her glove in the face of Miss
Shelby.
France was victorious.
During the second engagement the American
was lightly wounded on the arm.
Witnesses have stated that everything happened
according to the rules.
Fighting just until someone drew blood (as
opposed to the death or to the pain) was common
with lady duels.
For instance, in 1792, after one Mrs. Elphinstone
insinuated Lady Almeria Braddock was significantly
older than she was, the pair battled first
with pistols and then with swords in London’s
Hyde Park.
The result?
Their pistol shots missed, but the matter
ended as soon as Lady Braddock inflicted Elphinstone
with a light wound to the arm with her sword.
After receiving the wound, Mrs. Elphinstone
agreed to write a formal apology.
Perhaps the most famous “petticoat duel”
of them all was fought topless.
This likewise was supposed to be fought only
to first blood, but, apparently, between the
seriousness of the dispute and the ferocity
of the combatants, both ladies were ultimately
injured.
It began in the summer of 1892, when two Austrian
noblewomen, the Princess Pauline Metternich
and the Countess Anastasia Kiielmansegg, were
at each other’s throats over the matter
of the floral arrangements for the Vienna
Musical Theatrical Exhibition (the Princess
was the Exhibition’s Honorary President
and the Countess was the President of the
Ladies’ Committee).
Deciding the dispute could only honorably
be settled by armed combat, the women travelled
to the Vaduz on the Swiss frontier to duel
it out.
Attended by their seconds, Princess Schwarzenberg
and Countess Kinsk, as well as the medically-trained
Baroness Lubinska, on the advice of the Baroness,
the two duelists first stripped to the waist
before the battle.
More than mere bravado, and certainly not
for any salacious purpose, the Baroness had
the ladies remove their clothing due to the
possibility that small strips of cloth could
be trapped in any sword wounds, and might
thereby lead to the contraction of sepsis,
something she’d seen happen before in the
aftermath of duels.
Caused by, in pertinent part, a bacterial
infection of the bloodstream, the body’s
immune response can sometimes ultimately damage
organs or other tissues, and, in some cases,
lead to organ failure and even death.
As the fight was to begin, the few males that
were present (all servants) were sent to stand
far away with their backs to the battle.
The fight itself was reportedly relatively
short.
Both ladies made a few thrusts and feints
with their rapiers, resulting in princess
Pauline cutting countess Anastasia’s nose.
With first blood drawn, and supposedly in
some shock over having done so, the Princess
dropped her defenses.
Rather than cease fighting, the Countess subsequently
stabbed the Princess in the arm.
At the sight of the blood, it is reported
that both seconds fainted (see: Why Women
Fainted So Much in the 19th Century), and
hearing the ladies’ cries, the chivalrous
(or curious) footmen and coachmen supposedly
attempted to rush to their “aid.”
Since the Princess drew first blood, most
considered her the winner, although some felt
that the glancing blow wasn’t as worthy
of recognition as the Countess inflicting
a deeper arm cut.
Regardless, at the urging of their two seconds,
shortly after both were injured the duel ended
and the ladies
made up.